All right, so now we're ready to do a problem with springs.
Let's imagine that we have this spring pointing horizontally attached to a wall over here
and then over on the right side, we've got this 5 kg block moving at 2 m/s towards the spring.
We can imagine what's going to happen here, the block is going to push against the spring,
compress it a little bit, and then bounce back.
Then I want you to tell me--what is the maximum amount away from the equilibrium point
that this spring ever gets compressed--so what's the maximum value of Δx.
Now, as a hint to solving this problem--keep in mind that the point where this spring
will be most compressed is the point where the block's velocity becomes 0.
All right, keep that in mind and good luck solving the problem.